[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein sehr
beliebtes pfannenbrot das sind
marokkanische Samen und das ist ein Brot
aus Gries aus Mehl ein bisschen Hefe
wenig Aufwand und vor allem aus der
Pfanne und das liebe ich wir fangen
direkt an ich schreibe euch alle ganz
genau und Mengenangaben wie immer hier
unten in die Infobox und ich gebe jetzt
hier ein bisschen lauwarmes Wasser zu
meiner Trockenhefe natürlich
funktioniert das ganze auch mit frischer
Hefe aber ich muss sagen Trockenhefe
habe ich einfach immer da und frische
eben nicht immer das Ganze einmal gut
verrühren damit sich das auflöst also
ich benutze heute meine Küchenmaschine
zum Kneten einfach weil ich heute ein
bisschen faul bin aber ihr könnt auch
einfach mit den Händen kneten ich habe
jetzt hier Weichweizengrieß ganz wichtig
nicht Hartweizengrieß benutzen sonst
funktioniert das nämlich nicht so gut
und normales Mehl Typ 405 kommt hier
rein
sondern könnt ihr an der Stelle auch
schon
Salz und Zucker mit dazugeben
Zucker wenn ihr euch fragt okay warum
Zucker das passt einfach zum Geschmack
also gibt Zucker auf jeden Fall mit dazu
so und das ganze werde ich dann gleich
zusammen mit dem Wasser und mit unserer
Hefe Mischung verrühren
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt echt nur so ein paar
Sekunden geknetet und ich habe schon das
Gefühl der Teig ist ganz gut wichtig ist
dass ihr jetzt nicht das ganze was auf
einmal rein gibt aber das habe ich euch
so auch in die Infobox geschrieben und
jetzt knete ich das einfach nur noch
ganz kurz so ein bisschen was ist schon
ein relativ fester Teig aber nicht so
trocken das ist ganz wichtig und ich
benutze den jetzt komplett mit Öl gibt
den dann in meine Schüssel und lassen
zugedeckt bzw verschlossen 15 Minuten
entspannt dabei geht's nicht darum dass
irgendwie aufgeht oder so sondern das
einfach jetzt ähm der Grieß so ein
bisschen aufweichen kann und dann machen
wir nach 15 Minuten weiter
[Musik]
so der Teig kommt jetzt gut entspannen
ich habe vorab einmal Butter in der
Mikrowelle zerlassen und ich werde jetzt
die Butter zusammen mit Öl einmal
verrühren das brauchen wir gleich das
ist einfach nur die kurze Vorbereitung
[Musik]
so kurz an die Seite geben und jetzt
wird der Teig geteilt ich mache 12
müsste man ihr könnt auch wenn ihr die
ganzen einfach größer haben möchtet
könnt ihr da auch weniger draus machen
zum Beispiel sechs oder acht aber ich
finde 12 ist hier schon die perfekte
Größe der Teig ist richtig schön
angenehm weich
[Musik]
so lass die Teiglinge gerne noch mal 15
Minuten ruhen dann lassen sie sich
einfach viel besser verarbeiten und auch
immer schön zugedeckt so und jetzt nehme
ich mir immer ein Teigling ihr braucht
jetzt eigentlich gar kein ausfallstab
denn ihr nehmt euch einfach eure Hände
und funkt sie immer wieder in diese
Butter Öl Mischung und dann wird der
Teig einfach ausgebreitet so dass er
jetzt nicht reißt also man merkt auf
jeden Fall dass er sehr gut entspannt
hat der zieht sich nur noch ganz leicht
zusammen das ist normal und jetzt
versucht ihr den so breit wie möglich
rechteckig auszubreiten also es ist
eigentlich sogar wie so eine
Therapiestunde es ist wirklich sehr
entspannt und danach klappen wir ihn
einmal ein also links rechts oben unten
und das machen wir mit ein 12 Teigling
und danach geht's auch zum Herd
[Musik]
also ihr könnt zwischendrin immer wieder
ein bisschen Grieß verteilen nur so ein
bisschen es wird ja später wie so eine
Art feuchter Blätterteig also richtig
lecker wäre das noch nie ausprobiert hat
er sollte das unbedingt also das ist ein
Zeichen das ganze jetzt einmal nachholen
so nicht mache ist folgendermaßen wenn
ihr merkt okay ausbreiten geht nicht
mehr man sieht schon teilweise hier die
Silikonmatte durch dann klappt ihr das
einmal zur Hälfte ein und jetzt nehmt
ihr euch wieder die sauberen Finger
einmal rein in das Öl Buttermischung und
dann wieder bestreichen so das gleiche
mit der anderen Seite
das könnt ihr dann einfach da drüber
Lappen
so es muss jetzt auch nicht perfekt sein
und dann einmal von oben noch mal
umklappen hier zur Hälfte wieder Fett
dran machen jetzt habe ich Grieß
vergessen so schlimm ist es nicht aber
zwischendrin einfach weil man merkt das
einfach später beim Auspacken dann sieht
man noch mal die einzelnen Schichten und
das jetzt auch noch mal drüber Lappen so
fertig also das ist schon mal mein
erstes Päckchen das gebe ich jetzt so
einfach zur Seite hier darf auch noch
mal ein bisschen Öl dran das gebe ich so
zur Seite und dann ruht das hier sowieso
noch mal bis wir ausbacken dann
anschließend wird vom ausbacken noch mal
so ein bisschen flach angedrückt aber
das zeige ich euch gleich ich mache
jetzt erstmal die anderen 11 Teiglinge
weiter
[Musik]
jetzt geht es ans ausbacken das geht
auch super schnell und einfach ich habe
hier schon mal angefangen ich mache das
parallel mit zwei Pfannen ihr könnt
natürlich auch eine machen und dann
immer nacheinander es dauert wirklich
nicht lange ihr nehmt euch jetzt den
Teig gut das habe ich jetzt hier schon
vorbereitet deshalb nehme ich mir jetzt
einen neuen um euch das zu zeigen so und
den Teig den breiten wir jetzt mit den
Händen noch mal sehr dünn aus also 20 22
cm schon mindestens das geht auch wie
gesagt ganz easy mit den Händen die
Pfanne habe ich schon vorgewärmt vorhin
also ich habe erstmal auf Stufe 8
gemacht damit sie vorheizt und jetzt bin
ich so immer zwischen Stufe 6 und 7 von
9 also es sollte auch nicht zu heiß sein
damit äh das von außen eben nicht
verbrennt und ihr dürft es zwischendurch
auch gerne mehrmals wenden wenn ihr euch
unsicher seid die Schichten innen drin
die werden auf jeden Fall garen da
braucht ihr euch keine Sorgen machen so
jetzt gebe ich den da rein und dann
brauche ich von jeder Seite so ungefähr
zwei Minuten also insgesamt vier und so
backe ich sie nacheinander aus ganz
wichtig mein Tipp nehmt euch so ein
abkühlgitter das coole ist nämlich dass
hier unten nochmal Luft durchkommt und
wenn ihr das jetzt auf dem Teller legt
wo unten eben keine Luft durchkommt dann
matscht euch das und es sollte ja klar
weich sein aber auch so ein bisschen
knusprig also auch nicht übereinander
legen sonst werden sie labbrig legt sie
erstmal ruhig nebeneinander
[Musik]
so und jetzt kommt noch einen Schritt
des mir persönlich sehr wichtig und zwar
das ganze von oben bzw von außen noch
mal ein Pinsel mit Fett ihr könnt jetzt
Butter nehmen oder Öl oder übrigens das
ganze noch mal auf ein anderes Level
nicht immer so schön sage und in dem
buttergie ich glaube die die mich schon
seit Jahren verfolgen wissen dass ich
gold metal Butter die Liebe das ist so
das Original und da geht's auch mit dem
Pinsel rein und bestreicht dann jetzt
hier einfach noch mal von außen das gibt
richtig guten Geschmack und auch noch
mal ein bisschen Glanz Dose ist auch
schon wieder fast leer also ich benutze
sehr gerne gerade zum orientalischen
Bereich bei süßen oder auch bei Herzen
Rezepten so und dann ist es eigentlich
auch schon fertig und ich würde mal
sagen ich hole gleich den Hansa dazu
weil Hamster Experte und
schon ein bisschen Angst vor seiner
reaction aber ich glaube der wird nett
sein zu mir
[Musik]
den besonderen Tester
übertrieben kritisch immer allem
umziehen deswegen
marokkanische Küche liegen aber dem ist
nicht so
muss ich das anhören das ist so richtig
blättrigger vertragen aber perfekt
Honig und Frischkäse aber man kann ja
seine eigene Variante draus machen
oder so mega lecker gerade zum Frühstück
finde ich mega lecker und ich muss sagen
kein Unterschied zu deiner Mama
gefragt ja das denn so ein Ramadan und
das passt perfekt zu super perfekt
oder nachts morgens wenn man dann eben
sein Frühstück einnimmt dafür würde ich
jetzt doch ein bisschen zu ölig finden
aber zu Suppe optimal am besten so wenn
ihr so Gäste sind ne dann habt Ihr super
da und dann gesagt
der wird erstmal das ganze Essen bitte
scheiße scheiße
ich denke mal an Ramadan ich würde mir
jetzt so ein oder so einen halben nehmen
wenn ihr solche Rezepte nicht verpassen
möchtet und vor allem schreibt mir doch
gerne in die Kommentare ich weiß dass
das Interesse marokkanischen Rezepten
großes viele haben wir auch schon online
muss ich sagen aber schreibt doch gerne
mal wenn es ein Rezept ist was ich noch
nicht online hat schreibt mir jetzt in
die Kommentare oder machen wir das also
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]